do i have to call your lady stop now
yes
you shouldn't have run from the guards i
didn't run
you need better guards
what suits you lady stark
john left you in charge he did
i hope he comes back soon i remember how
happy he was to see me when he sees you
his heart will probably stop
it doesn't look like him should have
been carved by someone who knew his face
everyone who knew his face is dead
we're not
they say you killed joffrey did you
i wish i had
me too i was angry when i heard someone
else had done it
however long my list got he was always
first
your list of people i'm going to kill
how did you get back to winterfell it's
a long story
i imagine yours is two yes
not a very pleasant one my neither
but our stories aren't over yet
no they're not
you